The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOMER ULLMAN: So so far, we've
talked about just examples
of running things forward.
I hope I've given
you some examples
of different procedures
that you can run forward
to get some interesting
stuff, whether it's
a mixture of
Gaussians, whether it's
sort of this mixture of
Gaussian plus uniform,
whether it's just
flipping the coin.
But the question is, OK, I've
written down my forward model--
and hopefully, you saw that,
even if it was a little bit
broken, even if you didn't
get the full details,
it wasn't that hard to
write it down, right?
Someone could say,
listen, I think the way
the bombing works is this.
You're going to put a Gaussian.
You're going to put
another Gaussian maybe,
or maybe you're
going to put three.
I don't know how many.
And you can write that down.
And then you say, OK, I actually
want to do inference on that.
And that's when it becomes
a little bit painful to do.
And if only there was a way
of running forward your model
and, having written
the forward direction,
you can do inference.
And it looks like we're talking
about something completely
different, but
actually, it's not.
We're basically going
to run our models,
but we're going to run
our models in a way
that it's going to do inference.
So let's see.
How would we possibly do that?
So the basic syntax
for any sort of query--
any sort of
inference-- in Church
is by stating the
following procedure.
You start out with saying
query, where query is not itself
a command.
It's just there all
sorts of queries.
There's rejection query.
There's mh-query--
Metropolis Hastings.
There's explicit enumeration.
But the point is,
you would write down
that particular query,
then you would write down
the generative model.
This is a list of things--
the way that you
think the world works.
So here, for example, you
would put in the London bombing
example.
You would put in the list of
things like, I don't know,
it's either uniform
or not uniform,
it's either Gaussian
or not Gaussian.
You're going to put some
uncertainty in priors
and things like that.
Once you finish defining
your forward model of how
you think the
world works, you're
going to ask it a
particular thing.
The penultimate statement
that you're going to give it
is what we want to know.
For example, in this
particular case,
suppose that, before
I started, I said, I
don't know if the bombing
is targeted or not.
I'm 50/50 either way.
I don't have to be.
But let's say I'm
50/50 either way.
So I say, I'm going
to flip a coin.
It's either targeted
or it's not targeted.
And that's going to come
up either true or false.
And what you're going to
basically say-- you're
going to query on that.
You want to say, did the
coin come up true or false
given the data?
So the last thing--
the ultimate statement
that you're going to
write-- is basically
the conditional statement.
And the conditional statement
is basically the thing
that has to evaluate as true.
The usual thing that we
would write down there--
I'll give you some
examples of that--
but what we would usually
write is something like,
given that the observed
data matches the sample
data from my model.
So if you want to do
something like the probability
of a particular
hypothesis given the data,
this is the way that you
would say, this is my data.
This is what I know.
And the way that
it would know is,
you're sort of running
down a program,
and you're constraining
it to give you
a sample that matches the
actual thing that you see.
In the London
bombing example, what
you would do is you would
write something like query,
a bunch of defines--
targeted bombing, random
bombing, things like that--
I want to know--
is it targeted or random?
How did the coin fall?
And what you're going
to do is, you're
going to say, listen,
run this model forward
under the following condition.
If I just run it
forward, I would either
get targeted or not.
It would be 50/50--
under the condition
that whatever
this model samples has
to match the actual data.
So I'm going to run it
forward, but the thing
that it needs to
evaluate as true
is that the samples
I got from the model
are equal to the
actual data that I got.
Now once you do that--
once you define that particular
thing-- what you've done
is change the
probability distribution
that the generative
model describes.
Remember how we talked earlier--
I was sort of trying
to hammer it home--
that anything that you
write down as Church
is actually a
probability distribution.
You write down the
program and you
run it an infinite
number of times
and you get some distribution.
Your generative model describes
a particular distribution.
If you condition that
model on something,
you get a different
distribution.
And that different
distribution is now
what you're going
to sample from.
You're going to sample
from the posterior.
You have some prior, you
condition it on some data,
and you're going to
sample from the posterior.
And sampling from the posterior
can be something like--
and we'll give it
some examples, like, I
know how the world works
in terms of their objects,
and I know how light works,
and I know how vision works.
I don't know what the particular
objects in this world are.
That's what I want to know.
I condition on their
retinal display
being equal to something.
And now, my posterior
probability distribution
is going to basically
sample from, say,
your face or these
objects or these chairs.
Well, the same thing
could work, for example,
if you're trying to
query a sentence.
You're trying to parse
a sentence from sound,
or you're trying to predict
how the next step in a physics
engine is going to work, or
many, many, many, many, many
different other things that
you can find in probmods.org.
So like I said, the "what
we know" is the condition.
And if you set the
condition to true,
that's a sampling from
the generative model,
because you're always
going to evaluate as true.
Now, how could you
possibly implement
this sort of magical procedure?
So how could you take some
probability distribution
and change it into a different
probability distribution that
does what you want it to do?
And there are many, many
different ways of doing that.
But the easiest way of
doing that is by something
called rejection query.
How many of you know
about rejection sampling?
How many don't know
OK.
The way rejection
sampling works is
that I have some
sort of distribution
that I'm trying to sample from.
And suppose that it's
really hard to sample
from that distribution exactly.
So let's say that my
distribution is this circle.
And for whatever reason,
it's really, really hard
to sample from that circle.
I don't want to try to define
the probability distribution
that describes this circle.
It's really hard
to sample from it.
This is trivial, but there are
probability distributions that
are really hard to sample from.
What do you do?
You can construct a
really simple distribution
that you can sample from.
Let's say that it's really,
really simple for me to sample
from a uniform square that
encompasses the circle.
So now, I have some
probability distribution.
There's a uniform
distribution over the square
that I can sample from.
What does it mean
I can sample from?
It means each time
I run the procedure
I get some point in the square.
But I don't want the
points in the square.
I want only points
from the circle.
So what I would do is basically
sample from the square,
and each time it falls outside
the square, I'm going to say,
throw that out.
That's called
rejection sampling.
Because you sample from
some sort of procedure
that you know how
to sample from,
then you check that sample.
And if that sample didn't
meet your desiderata,
you throw it away.
And what you're left
with is the circle--
the distribution that
you're trying to get.
So what is the
simple thing and what
is the hard thing in what
we're describing so far?
The simple thing is
the generative model.
It's relatively easy to sample
from the generative model.
We just wrote it down.
So we know how to
sample from it.
But we're looking
for something else.
We're looking for some
sort of different program.
We're looking for
some sort of setting
of a program that would
generate the data that I saw,
not just the generative
model that I wrote.
The way that we would do
that is, in rejection query,
we would sample from
the generative model.
We would check, does
that fit what we know?
Suppose I just
sampled something.
And then I check, does
that apply to the condition
that I want?
So let's say I have
a particular world.
It's a sort of a silly world.
But let's just make sure it
works given the last time.
OK.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to describe a world in
which there is Legolas.
Gimli, and Arwen.
Anyone get Lord of the Rings
references or something
like that?
OK.
Each one of them is
going to take out
a particular number of orcs.
And let's say that's
my generative model
is that I don't know how many
each one of them took out.
Let's say that they take
anything between zero and 20.
They're having a brawl.
Each one of them is going to
take out some number of orcs.
So we're going to define
the number of orcs
that Legolas took out
as some random integer--
20.
OK?
Gimli's the same.
Arwen's the same.
And we're going to also define
the total number of orcs
that they took out as just
plus each one of these things.
So we're going to look
at the pile of orcs
that they took out in the end.
That's my generative model.
That's it.
What I'm going to
wonder about is,
how many orcs did
Gimli take out?
Not knowing anything, how
many orcs did Gimli take out?
Should we just switch
to kill or something?
I feel bad for the orcs.
But OK.
How many orcs did
Gimli take out?
Well, we don't know.
We just said we don't know.
It's a random integer
between zero and 20.
It's anyone's guess.
If I just ran this
model forward,
it would give me any
number between zero and 20.
If I ran it 1,000 times, I
would get a uniform distribution
over zero and 20.
Now, I'm going to
give you a condition.
It's a simple condition.
The total number of orcs
that they all took out
is greater than 45.
Altogether, Gimli,
Arwen, Legolas
took out more than 45 orcs.
Now, how many orcs do you
think that Gimli took out?
Now, the point is
that you would somehow
shift your distribution.
This is a very simple problem.
You could probably write
it down on a notepad.
But you're trying to do the
posterior of the number of orcs
that Gimli took out, given--
conditioned on-- the
fact that all of them
together took out more than 45.
Is this making sense?
OK.
How would I write down
that as a rejection query
without using any syntax that
you haven't seen already.
Without using anything
like query yet,
I'm just going to
use, basically,
recursion to write down a
rejection query for that.
And later on, you can
use a rejection query.
But what I would do
is, I would just say,
here's a procedure
that's going to give me
back the number of orcs
that Gimli took out
conditioned on everyone
taking out more than 45.
So I write down a
particular generative model.
Like, I know that Legolas
took out somewhere
between zero and 20, Gimli
took out somewhere zero and 20,
Arwen took out somewhere
between zero and 20,
and they all took out
the number of total orcs.
Now I say this.
If the total number of
orcs is greater than 45,
that's a good sample.
So I'm going to go through this.
I'm going to sample my program.
I'm going to get, Gimli did--
I don't know--
15.
Legolas did 10.
So now, say, Arwen did 20
or something like that.
So now we got to 45.
Is that a good world?
Yes, we're over 45.
Fine.
Give me back whatever
it was for Gimli.
I don't even
remember what it was.
Give me that back.
Suppose it didn't add up to 45.
Try again.
This is basically the circle
and square example from before.
The if statement is telling us,
if this matches my condition,
sample randomly from the world.
Sample from the square.
Sample from the
generative model.
If the thing that you got
matches the condition that you
want, give me back the sample.
Give me back that answer.
If it didn't, try again.
And now, if we do this, and
we repeat this procedure
1,000 times, then it's no
longer uniform distribution.
It's greater than
five or whatever.
It's going to be zero on that.
Because if he took out
zero, they're never
going to get to 45, right?
And it's probably going
to be sort of skewed
in this direction.
So that's the
posterior distribution
on how many orcs Gimli took
out conditioned on all of them
taking out more than 45.
That's amazing, you guys.
You've just understood
rejection query.
You've just written down, in a
few very simple lines of code,
a sampling with rejection.
And in fact, you can
define all of conditioning
using this thing.
You don't have to get fancy with
Metropolis Hastings and things
like that if you're just
trying to sort of prove things.
If you're into computer
science and things like that,
you can just define
conditioning using this.
You're saying, I have some
probability distribution.
I'm trying to condition it.
I get a different probability
distribution-- the posterior.
How well behaved is it?
Can I write down?
Things like that--
you can prove it.
All the sort of things
that you want to prove,
you can prove using something
like this construction.
Why shouldn't you use that?
So you can do that if you're
into theoretical computer
science.
What is bad about
rejection query?
Does anyone know?
Can you guess?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's costly.
TOMER ULLMAN: Costly
in what sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: Right.
Exactly.
Depending on the condition, it
might be a very, very bad idea.
Here, I could sort
of do the condition,
because I ran the model forward,
and sometimes, I got over 45.
So yeah, why is rejection query
a particularly bad example?
Because your condition
might be really,
really, really hard to satisfy.
So if, for example,
I change this to 59,
what will happen now?
I think because of
the way I wrote this,
it will never reach that.
But thanks for that point.
But let's change this to this.
Don't run this, by the way,
because it will never stop.
Or it will take a long time.
So now, it's only going to be
fulfilled if each one of them
took out 20 orcs, right?
They would all need to take out
20 orcs for the total number
of orcs to be equal to 60.
When is that going to happen?
It's going to happen 1 in 20
times 1 in 20 times 1 in 20.
You're going to waste a
lot of samples on something
that's never going to happen.
And it doesn't even
matter that much.
And you can easily look at
this and you can sort of say,
well, obviously, Gimli
took out more than this,
because I know how to program
and I can figure it out.
But oftentimes, you will find
that you can't exactly say.
You look at some
convoluted program
and you won't exactly
know how this should look
or whether it's easy
or whether it's hard.
But in that sense, rejection
query is probably a bad idea.
Another example of
why it's a bad idea
is something like precision.
So let's see.
Don't run this, because
it'll take forever.
Let's do an estimate of pi.
And again, I was sort of going
to give this as an exercise.
But since we don't
have a lot of time,
here's one thing that you
could do with rejection query,
or you can do it with
any sort of query.
You could try to estimate pi.
Literally, using that
example that I just did,
you could try to say, OK,
sample from some square,
only accept the Xs
that are in the circle,
and then sort of try to
estimate how many samples you
got in the circle out of
the total number of samples
you took.
So run 1,000 samples, and
see how many of those fall
in the square.
And if you run 1,000, you'll
get three point something.
You can try this.
I did it as an exercise for you.
You can see I sort of set
up some of this syntax.
If you want to try this
out later, please do.
You run 10,000
samples, it's like 3.1.
I think if you do it 100,000,
it'll probably do 3.14--
maybe not that much better.
Like, 100,000 samples,
seriously, to get 3.14--
we all know it's 3.1415.
Sometimes, if you
can use math, you
should use math, in some cases.
On the other hand--
this is, by the way, a reason
why you should probably not
use sampling in general
when you can use math.
We can solve it analytically--
if you're interested in
precision and things like that.
But suppose you're not
interested in precision.
I'm actually going
to try and help that.
So you can actually get
a pretty good estimate
from about 10 samples.
If you just do 10
samples on this thing,
you'll probably hit something
like three as an estimate.
You can do the histogram
for where it will fall.
Most of the samples--
like 70% of the samples--
will fall between 2.8 and 3.6.
If that's what you
care about, then that
might be what all your
vision system cares about,
or different things that
might require sampling.
Then that's fine.
And I'm not going to
go too much into this,
because, like I said, the dream
of probabilistic programming
is sort of to free
you from thinking
too much about the sampling.
But those of you that are
interested in sampling,
that are interested in
algorithmic learning and things
like that, there's been a lot
of research on exactly that.
When are we OK with
just taking one sample?
We write down some
sort of model and we
see how well the model does by
taking one sample, 10 samples.
What's the precision
that you can get?
And does that
precision match people
trying to perform a similar
task of estimating that thing?
That's, again, like the
sampling hypothesis-- not
sampling hypothesis for neurons,
sampling hypothesis for the way
people answer questions.
They sample one or
two or a few number
of points from their generative
model-- not that many.
And the claim is
that you can sort of
see that they get better
with time, that they probably
don't take that much if you
give them more time to think.
It looks a bit like
a sampling procedure
that takes more samples.
And it seems like you can
get away with quite a lot
if you just do 10 samples
or 100 samples for pi.
And there's this SMBC
cartoon that I quite
like, which is like,
why shouldn't physicists
teach geometry?
And they're like, well,
you know, how do I
remember the value of pi?
It's quite simple.
I look at my fingers and
there's five of them,
and that's about pi.
What else could
we do if we don't
want to use rejection
query, if we don't
want to use rejection sampling?
Suppose we don't.
We probably don't.
We could try to do
exhaustive enumeration.
If our model is small
enough, we can just
consider all the possibilities
and explicitly score them.
The other thing that we
could do is something
like Metropolis Hastings.
How many of you are familiar
with Metropolis Hastings?
OK.
Why don't we raise our
hands to the degree
that we are familiar with
Metropolis Hastings, where
here is really familiar,
here is not familiar.
OK.
Metropolis Hastings--
I'm not going
to go too much into the details.
I'll just be doing
it a disservice.
But the way to think about
it is to say, instead of just
sampling at random from the
entire space of things that
could be really, really bad
equally, I'm going to try
and sample from something that
I think is likely to be good.
And the way I'm
going to do that is,
I'm going to
construct, basically--
what's the best way
to explain this?
It's to say, I'm at a
particular point in the space.
I've gotten my sample.
I already have it.
What should I do now?
Rejection sampling just says,
well, just sample another one
from the generative model
and see if that works.
That's a bad idea.
What you should
actually do is try
to use the sample
that you already have
and how good it is as a sample
to inform your next move.
So now, what you're
going to do is,
you're in this particular
point in space,
and you're going to move to a
different point in space that
depends on the point
that you are now.
So for example, if you're in
some two-dimensional space,
and you're over here,
you're not going to sample
from this square.
You're going to sample from a
point next to it, let's say.
That's your proposal.
You sample according to
your proposal distribution.
Your proposal
distribution tells you
where you should sample next.
So you're here in the space
of all possible programs
or your theory space.
Metropolis Hastings is more
than just programs-- anything.
You're in the space
of possible things
that you're trying
to sample from.
You're here.
You've got one sample.
Now, you're sort
of looking around,
and you take another sample.
You do that according to
your proposal distribution.
Your jump there.
And you evaluate this point.
And the way that
you evaluate it is,
you just look, how well does
this thing fit the data?
And we can get into
that-- but the ways
you sort of score your
model according to the data.
And you say, well, this one
fits the data pretty well.
How well does this
one fit the data?
Not so great.
So I should probably
move over there.
I should move to that
point in program space.
I'm going to move over here.
Now I sample another point.
I go over here.
How well does this do?
Not as great, but I
might still accept it.
The point is, you're
going to accept and reject
new points, new
executions of the program
according to how they
predict the data,
according to how well
they answer the condition.
If the condition is
a simple true-false,
that just means that you
have an absolute yes or no.
But many of these
conditions are going
to be something like, well,
it's good if it matches it.
You get some score from the
likelihood and the prior.
So you can score this new
point in program space
and either accept or reject it.
And this thing of moving
around in program space
and sampling according to
some new proposal distribution
and accepting or rejecting
and moving around like that
is a lot more efficient in most
cases than rejection sampling.
And in the limit, if
you keep on doing this--
if you keep on walking around,
walking around, taking samples,
accepting or rejecting
them depending
on how well this new point
in program states does--
what you'll end up with is
the posterior distribution
that you're trying
to sample from.
And I should say, what is
a point in program space?
It just means a program that
I have completely evaluated.
Like in the case of the
London bombing, it would be,
I have two Gaussians, and
this one's center is here,
and this one's center is here.
I sort of walk through all
the things that I can sample.
I've gotten one particular
run of the program.
And then I try to move
to somewhere else.
Like, I might change the
center of this Gaussian.
Or I might say,
well, you know what?
Actually, there
aren't two Gaussians.
Let's run it again.
There was actually 10.
So what I do, the
way I change, the way
I move around in
program space is
to go to a particular
point along the tree
of the evaluation and say,
what if I change that?
What would I end up with?
I sort of re-sample.
And I re-sample.
I end up with some
other program.
I basically say,
how good is that?
Yes, no-- and I
accept or reject that.
As I said, I'm doing this a
little bit of a disservice.
But if you keep that mental
image in your head of something
bouncing around and
accepting or rejecting
new proposals according to how
well they do compared to one
another in a sort
of pairwise fashion,
you won't go far wrong.
What this also tells you is
that it's a little bit important
where you start out.
So if I start out in this
particular point in program
space, or in any space,
and I look locally,
I might accept or reject
and things like that,
but, actually, the really
good stuff is over here.
The high probability
stuff is over here.
But it'll take me a long
time to get to that.
Because I started out here.
Does everyone sort of understand
what I mean when I say "here?"
So supposing you
have a random square,
and you're trying to
sample from a probability
distribution over the
square, and in the corner
is this much less probability.
But you started on the
corner for whatever reason.
And now, you're
trying to figure out
how to get to those good
samples in the center,
but you can only move locally.
You will eventually
get to the center.
If you run this on
long enough, you
will eventually get to those
good probability spaces.
But it depends a lot on
where you started out.
And that just means that,
oftentimes, in Metropolis
Hastings and MCMC
and things like that,
you hear about
burn-in, which is just
to say, we want to get rid
of the initial x samples,
because those samples
are going to be biased.
They're going to depend
on where we started out.
And the hope is that,
after x samples,
we're no longer biased.
We no longer remember
where we started from.
We're just sort of sampling
around in the space.
So the way Metropolis
Hastings works--
and this is the backbone
of inference in Church--
is, you would write down
something like mh-query,
then you would write down
the number of samples
that you want from your
posterior distribution.
You would write down the lag.
The lag is just to say,
forget every x steps.
If you want to talk about this,
we can talk about it later.
It's not particularly
interesting.
These are just two numbers.
And if you make them bigger,
you will get more samples.
You will get a better estimate
of your posterior distribution.
You write down some
generative model,
you write down what
you want to know,
and you write down
what you actually know.
And you do a random walk in
the program evaluation space.
Like Josh said,
what's nice about
this is that it's very,
very, very, very general.
This will work on any
program, more or less,
defined correctly.
You need to make some decisions,
like how many samples you
want to take, what the lag
is, what the burn-in is.
You can do all
sorts of fanciness.
You can do particle filtering.
You could run several chains.
You can do temperate annealing.
You can do lots of
different things
that I just said and might
not make a lot of sense.
But the point is that
this procedure could
be made more or less fancy.
One of the problems with
it is, it takes a while.
Like Josh said, there's a
lot of better algorithms.
If you know what your
representation is, and it's
something like a
feedforward neural network,
you probably shouldn't do
Metropolis Hastings on it.
There's a lot of
very fast things
that you could do,
like gradient descent,
and you don't need
to wait around
for this thing to happen.
Let's see.
So I think we have
enough time to give you
some examples of inference.
Let's walk through some
coin testing examples,
a bit of intuitive
physics, and a little bit
of social reasoning.
So suppose that I took
a coin and I flipped it,
and it came up heads.
What do you think?
Is this coin weird?
No.
It's OK to say no.
What if I flipped and it got
heads five times in a row.
Do people think it's weird?
Raise your hand to the
degree that it's weird.
Is it weird that it's five?
If I flipped it 10 times
and it came up heads,
raise your hands to the
degree that it's weird.
15 times in a row, heads?
20 times in a row, heads?
OK, we more or less asymptoted
somewhere between 10 and 15,
which is exactly right.
And the point here is something
like, we have a particular
prior over what we think
the weight of the coin is.
We're pretty sure that
the coin is not biased.
We're pretty sure
that the coin is
supposed to be equal weighted.
But then we get more
and more evidence,
and we sort of figure
out that, wait a minute,
no, this might be a trick coin.
This might be weird.
And the point of
the first example
is to show you the basics of
conditioning and inference
and things like that
using the coin example.
So what we would do
is, we would take in--
and again, as I said, I'm
slightly going to rush this.
But I'll still
try to explain it.
We're going to define
some observed data.
Suppose our observed
data is that we
got five heads in a row.
Is that five?
Yes.
It's five.
And now we're going
to say, OK, we're
going to define something.
We're going to define
an inference procedure.
We're going to call it samples.
The way it's going to
work is that it's going
to give us 1,000 samples back.
We said we're going
to write mh-query,
the number of
samples, and now we're
going to define a
generative model.
We're going to end
up with the thing
that we're actually interested
in under a certain condition.
So what's our model
for the world--
for this simple world?
Let's say my prior on this
being a fair coin is very high.
One means I'm absolutely
sure it's a fair coin.
Zero means it's not a fair coin.
And we're going to put in a big
prior on it being a fair coin.
It's going to be 0.999.
And then we're going
to basically say,
somewhere in the
beginning, the way
I think the world works is
that you're going to pull up
a new coin off the mint,
and you're going to say,
is it a fair coin or not?
999 out of 1,000 are fair.
One is not.
So we're basically saying this.
We're going to say,
is it a fair coin?
And this is going to come up
true 999 times out of 1,000.
And it's going to come up
false one time out of 1,000.
Because what we're
basically doing here
is just flipping a coin.
We're flipping a coin
with a bias of this prior.
So what we have
here is this thing
is going to come up
this thing-- fair coin.
It's going to come up
without any knowledge,
without any data,
without seeing anything.
Just, you took a
coin off the mint.
999 times out of
1,000, you think
it's going to be fair,
without seeing any data.
Now you're going
to create a coin.
The coin is going to
take in some weight.
There's this procedure that
you can flip and actually get
heads or tails.
And the way this coin is going
to work is that, if it's fair,
it's going to have
a weight of 0.5.
If it's unfair-- and this
is a very simple example--
it's going to have
a weight of 0.95.
So the fair coin comes up
heads or tails equally likely.
The unfair coin-- the
trick coin-- comes up
heads almost all the time.
And again, you can define
a different hypothesis.
It doesn't really matter.
But the point is, I
defined some sort of coin.
And now, I define some
sort of hypothesized data.
Well, the hypothesized data is
just, I sample from this coin
that I just made.
And what I want to know
is, is this a fair coin?
Yes or no.
The last statement
is conditioned
on this sample data,
this illusory data,
this imagined data being
equal to the observed data.
So now, you have
some sort of program,
and you're trying to figure
out, did this come out
to be a fair coin or not?
When I did this here, if I
didn't condition on anything,
then it, 999 times out of
1,000, should give me back,
yes, this is a fair coin.
But I've now conditioned
on some data.
And the data is that it came
up five times heads in a row.
And if you do a
histogram for that,
then you'll find that it's still
very likely to be a fair coin.
Because the prior is so strong.
But now, we can change.
We can change the data to
add a few more heads here.
And I think we're now
more or less at 10.
And it's starting
to be like, well,
is it a fair coin-- yes or no?
Well, I'm like 60% sure
that it's a fair coin now.
What if I flipped it--
I don't know-- like 20 times
or something like that,
and I came up with that?
And it's basically saying that
it's 100% not a fair coin.
This is false.
It's basically saying,
is it a fair coin?
No.
Even though the
prior is strong--
even though if I just
ran my generative model
without any conditions, usually,
it would be a fair coin,
there is no way that I would run
my generative model and sample
it 20 times--
that coin flip-- and it would
come up heads all the time,
when the alternative is that
it's going to come up heads.
So now, you can sort of
play around with this coin.
This is a nice example.
And by the way,
Josh, some version
of this-- not much more
complicated than that--
was a cognition paper
a few years ago,
where, basically,
you gave people
different sequences of coins,
different sequences of numbers,
and you started to see,
where does it become weird?
What hypothesis did
they think is likely?
And all that they did was,
they gave it a more interesting
hypothesis space.
Instead of saying it's either
a fair coin or a coin that's
95% heads, they gave you a
more general hypothesis space.
Like, it could be a coin that
comes mostly heads, mostly
tails.
Maybe it's a coin that does
heads, tails, heads, tails,
heads, tails, heads, tails.
Or you can define the sort
of alternative procedure,
but that, you would
change over here.
The rest of this would
stay more or less the same.
That's a very simple way of
getting some hypothesis tested.
Let's do some very
simple, intuitive physics.
Let's try something like this.
So in Church, you can basically
animate physics forward.
I guess I hadn't counted
on, when it's a full screen,
it sort of does that thing.
But what you can do
is, you can define,
basically, a
two-dimensional world
where you say, listen, here's
a two-dimensional world.
It's this big.
I'm going to add some shapes.
I'm going to put the
shapes in random locations.
I'm going to set
gravity to something.
And then I'm going
to run it forward.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: Command minus.
TOMER ULLMAN: Sorry?
TOMER ULLMAN: Command
minus for running?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: Oh, of course.
Thank you.
Trivial.
Is that better, everybody?
Yeah.
OK.
So I have this
thing, and I'm going
to hit simulate to try
and see what happens.
So I basically
have these things.
I guess, in this case, I
didn't put any randomness
on where they actually are.
But you could easily
imagine putting
some randomness on where
these blocks start out,
where these blocks are.
But the point is, this is just
running it forward in physics.
Now what is that good for?
Well, you could, for
example, define a tower.
A tower is just defining
a bunch of blocks,
one on top of the other.
And now you can run it
forward, see what happens.
What do you think?
Is this going to fall or not?
Yes?
No?
Let's see.
And you can simulate
that forward.
It fell.
OK.
Very nice.
Now what can we do with that?
And as I said, I'm going
to zoom through this.
What we can define is basically
a bunch of towers like this.
Each one of them is just saying,
the blocks are like that.
And all I'm going to do
is slightly perturb them
and see if they fall down.
And I'm going to do that
1,000 times for each tower.
for a bunch of towers.
Some of them are stable.
Some of them are not stable.
So you can write down
some Church code, which
is basically, this is my world.
There's some ground.
The ground is just a rectangle.
Here's a tower-- a stable tower.
The stable tower--
all that it means
is that I'm creating some
blocks in this particular order.
Here's an almost stable tower.
It's blocks in this order.
Here's an unstable tower.
It's blocks in that order.
And now, what I'm
going to do is,
I'm going to run this
tower many times,
and I'm going to count
up the number of times
that it actually fell.
And if you do that, you'll see
that the stable tower didn't
fall down.
This is just saying,
like, did it fall down--
false, true?
This one didn't fall
down any of the time.
This one fell down
some of the time.
This one fell down all the time.
It's a toy example.
But it's actually a toy example
of a very nice and interesting
paper that came
out very recently
and shows something deep
about intuitive physics.
We can ask how hard it was
to implement this thing.
This is an implementation
of liquid physics in not so
much Church as webPPL.
And what they were trying to do
here is to sort of say, well,
this is a bunch of water.
Physics is frozen right now.
Imagine that this is
a big glob of water.
This is a cup over here.
And this is some barrier.
So if the water falls
down on the barrier,
it's going to go
every which way.
So let's see.
If we run it, one of the
questions that we can ask
here-- and this has sort
of been an example--
what I'm trying to show
you here is that this
is an active area of research.
Even though it's sort of like
Church-- it's 2D physics.
It's simple.
But people have been
doing what they've
been porting in as a liquid
physics thing into Church.
That took them a
little bit of time.
You probably want to
talk to people who know
what they're doing in that.
Save yourself some time and talk
to people in a Goodman's group.
But what they did is, they
ported it in a liquid physics
implementation into Church.
And they sort of said, OK, now
we have some liquid physics
and we can try to
ask some questions.
Like, suppose that this
glob is going to fall down.
We set it down over here
and it's going to fall down.
Where should we put this
block in order to get as much
of the liquid into that cup?
That's an interesting question.
It shows something
about intuitive physics
of liquids and things like
that, more than just objects.
So the way that you
would do that is, even
in a simple world like this,
you would basically say,
fine, put this thing
somewhere, randomly uniform,
conditioned on
getting as much water
into this thing as possible.
And then try to figure out
where this block should go.
So you start out
uniform, condition
on as much water as possible.
You'll get some
posterior distribution
of where to place this block.
And just to show you what that
looks like, let's try to--
so suppose that we
actually tried to run this.
So in this case, you
don't want the block
to go there, for example, right?
Because most of the water is
going to slosh over there.
What if we put it over there?
It's a little bit better.
That's not so great.
You could run it many,
many different times.
At this point, I
hope most of you,
even if you don't quite
know what you're doing,
you can see how you would
go about writing the program
to figure this out.
You would write down the physics
world, assume most of that
is taken care of for you.
All you need to do
is sort of figure
out where to place this block,
put some uniform distribution
in this area, condition on
most of the water landing here,
and then just sample, and figure
out where this thing should
be in the world.
And that's pretty cool.
So here's another example.
That was intuitive physics.
Let's move on to
intuitive psychology,
which Josh was sort of getting
out at the end of his lecture.
And here's a very,
very simple question,
which is something like,
suppose that you see an agent--
this guy with googly eyes.
Can people see him
from way down there?
There's a guy with googly eyes.
It doesn't matter.
It's me.
I'm right here.
There's a banana over there.
There's an apple over here.
So there's the banana over
there, apple over there,
and I start walking over here.
And now, someone asks you,
why did Tomer go over there?
And you say, well, I guess
he wanted the banana.
And you say, oh, but you don't
have access to his goals.
How do you know he
wanted the banana?
And you say, well, because
he went to the banana.
Well, you're just
being circular.
How would you actually
solve a task like this?
It's sort of trivial.
And you could solve it
through something like cues.
You could say
something like, well,
the thing that you
approach is your goal.
But another thing
that you could do
is, you could say, well, I
assume that the way Tomer
works is that he has goals.
I don't know what his goals are.
But I assume he has goals.
And I assume that he can plan to
reach those goals in some sort
of semi-efficient manner.
And he has some beliefs
about the world.
And he's going to carry out
some sort of planning procedure
in order to get to his goals.
And if Tomer wanted the banana,
the action he should take
is to do this.
It would be very unlikely
for him to do this.
If he wanted the apple, he
would do that, not that.
So you could sort of use
this planning procedure
to set the knobs
on your procedure.
Think of it like a
generative model.
Your generative
model is something
that goes from goals or
utilities and beliefs
to something like actions.
And you would define the goals.
Let's say you don't
know what my goals are,
so you place some
distribution over them.
And then you get
to see my actions.
And you basically
try to say, well,
in program space, what would
be the setting of the goals
of Tomer, such that it would
have produced the observed
actions.
And if you write down
a model for that,
you'll find that if I set
the goal for Tomer as banana,
I'll get the observed
action, which is,
he walked towards the banana.
Similarly, for belief, if
you know something like,
you know there are
two boxes here.
You don't know
what's inside them.
You know it's either
a banana or an apple.
And you know that I really
love bananas and I hate apples.
And you see me walking
towards this box.
You can infer that,
ah, he probably
thought that was
a banana inside,
or he knew there
was a banana inside.
And again, if you had some
sort of planning procedure,
you would say, OK, it
would make sense for me
to set his belief to be banana,
because the outcome of that,
if I run the model forward
with those settings,
would be for him to
walk in that direction.
Now let me show you
just one example
of what that sort of
model would look like.
So this would be under
intuitive psychology.
Those of you who are
interested in sort of inference
over inference and,
how do agents reason
about other agents, or
goal inference or things
like that, you might want to
take a look at this section.
And this is sort
of super simple.
There's no probabilities,
exactly, in the sense of,
it's going to be either
this goal or that goal.
It's obviously something that
can be modified if you want to.
Does everyone more or less
see what's going on here?
Let me make that a bit bigger.
What I tried to write down is
a model in which someone went
for an apple, and you're
trying to figure out,
why did he go for that?
Yes.
Sorry.
It really should be over here.
Now, let me start out, actually,
with something like planning.
Let's write down the forward
model before we do inference.
Before we do inference,
let's write down
how we think the world works.
The thing that I said--
the way the world works
is that Tomer has some
goals and some beliefs.
And given his goals,
he'll take some action
to achieve his goals.
Let's write down that part.
That's the forward part.
If we can write down
the forward part,
the inference part
comes for free.
We just put that in
an mh-query and say,
what's the goal that made
the observed thing happen?
So what we would do is, we
would write down something like,
what action should Tomer take?
Choose an action.
It's a procedure.
It's a procedure that
takes on a particular goal.
Here, it's a particular
condition that I can satisfy.
But it could be a utility.
It could be anything.
But it's, what
action should I take,
given a particular goal, given
how I think the world works?
That's a transition function.
If I take this action,
what will happen?
I need to know that if I go
left, from your perspective,
I'll get to the banana.
That's the transition
function for the world.
And I need some initial state.
And now, I sample some action.
I do an action at random.
I either go left or go right.
I sample it from
some action prior.
Suppose it's completely uniform.
Define action.
It's simple action prior.
And suppose my prior
is go left, go right,
with equal probability.
Everyone with me so far?
We're trying to get a procedure
that will give us an action.
What action should I take?
Imagine you took an action.
It doesn't matter which one.
Now, what action did you
end up with conditioned
on that action getting
you to your goal?
This is a rejection query.
I'm trying to sample
an action conditioned
on that action
getting me to my goal.
So let's say I
sample the action.
I hypothesize that
I go that way.
Did I satisfy my goal?
No.
I ended up with the apple.
Do it again.
Run it again.
Now I sample the
action "go here."
Did I end up with a banana?
Yes.
OK.
So what action did I take?
I went, from your
perspective, left.
Return that.
We've just written down
a procedure for planning.
And it can be made
much more complex
than that in a few short steps.
By complex, I don't mean that
it's hard for you to follow.
I mean that it can take
in multiple worlds,
multiple steps,
utilities, probabilities,
things like that.
And it will spit out a
sequence of actions for you
to go from x to y
to get to your goal.
And it's written as
planning as inference.
Now, there are many different
types of planning procedures.
You could write down Markov
decision planning processes.
You could write down
rapid random trees.
I'm just throwing out names
there for those of you who
are interested in these things.
There's lots of ways
of doing planning.
This is one particular
way of doing planning.
You could have done
many different ways.
But the point is that we assume
you can even sort of wrap this
up in something.
Like I, as the observer--
I as you-- don't need to
know exactly how Tomer works.
I just need to know that
there is some procedure such
that if I put into it
a goal, and somehow,
how the world works, it will
spit out some rational action.
It's preferable that I have
some idea of how it works.
It doesn't need to
be the right one.
It doesn't need to be the
one that I actually use.
But you need to have
some sort of sense
that I am planning somehow.
This is one way to plan.
And now, this is
just showing you.
I put some uniform prior
on the action prior.
I either go left or right.
The transition
function of the world
is such that if you go
left, you get an apple.
If you go right,
you get a banana.
So that's from my
perspective, I guess.
If you do anything
else, you get nothing.
And then you sort
of just say, my goal
is, did I get to
the apple, let say,
or did I get to the banana?
I put that into
the choose action
and I'll end up going left.
Because my goal was
to get to the apple.
The apple was on the left.
I'm going to choose an action
in order to go to the left.
This whole thing is just to show
you that, in fact, this works.
If you sample it forward, it
will give you the right action.
You can now wrap up this
whole thing in something
that does goal inference, that
doesn't know that my goal was
this, that puts a uniform
prayer on this thing,
and then runs forward many,
many different samples
and comes to the conclusion that
it must have been the apple,
because he went left.
And again, this example is fully
written out for you over here,
as well as the belief inference.
This is an example
of implicature.
How many of you know
what implicature means,
like Gricean implicature?
It's the sort of thing
where someone tells me, hey,
are you going to
the party tonight?
And I say, I'm washing my hair.
Or you say something like, how
good of a lecturer was John?
And I say, well, he
was speaking English.
I'm not exactly telling
you he was a bad lecturer.
But if he was a good one.
I would say it.
The fact that I didn't say--
the fact that I chose
to say something else--
implies that he probably
wasn't a good lecturer.
And this sort of happens a lot.
And that it works is that-- and
this happens a lot in language
games, social games,
reasoning about reasoning--
I'm the speaker.
You're the listener.
I have some model of you.
You have some model of me.
I know that you know
that I would have
said he was a good lecturer.
I know that you know that.
If I wanted to, I
would have said that.
And I'm not.
So I know that you
know that I know that.
And it works out
such that you realize
that he's not a good lecturer.
And that sounds
sort of convoluted.
But it's actually not that bad.
And I want to show you an
example of how that works.
And this particular
example is based
on the "some not all" example.
So this is the sort of thing
like, I'm a TA in a class
and someone asks me, how did
the students do on the test?
And I say, some of the
students passed the test.
Do you think I mean, all the
students passed the test?
No.
Now, why not?
Because some, in a
sense, also means all.
All the students is true
if some is something
like a logical thing that
means greater than five
or greater than zero or greater
than one-- whatever it is.
It can include all.
But if it was all, I
would have said all.
And if it was one, I
would have said one.
So people are likely to
infer from me saying some,
that I probably mean--
if there's 100 students
and I say some,
they can give you a distribution
over what I mean by that.
And that distribution
depends on the alternatives--
the alternative words
I could have used,
which they know I didn't.
But they know I could have.
There's a nice example
of scaler implicature
and how it would
work in probmods.
What I want to show you is a
slightly different example,
which is, again, the
London bombing example.
But the way it would work
is something like this.
So here's the background
for implicature.
I came up with this yesterday.
I'm not quite sure it'll work.
But we'll see.
Imagine that things
work like this.
The city of London
is being bombed.
Again, sorry for the
slightly dire things.
The city of London
is being bombed,
and there are three
places it could be bombed.
Again, it's this uniform square.
It could be bombed
in the blue part--
anywhere here.
If it's bombed there
in the blue part,
I would say it was
bombed outside London.
That means outside London.
It doesn't include these things.
It's just outside London.
If it was bombed anywhere
in this red square--
so imagine that this
square is something like--
I don't know-- zero to two, and
over here, it's zero to one.
Anywhere in the red
square is called London.
If a bomb fell there, I would
say, a bomb during the blitz
dropped on London.
If someone asked me,
where did the bomb fall,
I would say, in London.
But that includes
this whole thing.
It also includes Big Ben.
Big Ben is in London.
Maybe some of you can
see what I'm getting at.
So if it fell on Big Ben, I
could say it fell on Big Ben.
I can say it fell in London,
because that's also true.
If it fell here, I would
say it fell in London.
say it fell outside London.
Now, there's a general, and a
staff sergeant walks up to him,
and he says, a bomb fell
on London during the blitz.
And the general says,
where did it fall?
And he says, it fell in London.
And the general says, OK.
Then he looks outside
his window and he says,
good god, it hit Big Ben!
And he says, yes, I
said it fell in London.
That's very weird.
We don't expect
people to do that.
And Gricean implicature
says we shouldn't do that.
But Grice said it
in a way that's
like, you should give
the maximal amount
of helpful information and
not hold out other things.
How would that fall out
of a particular model?
Well, the way it would fall
out is something like this.
And again, I'll show
you the code for that.
It's something like,
there's the speaker.
The speaker is the
staff sergeant.
He could choose one
of three words--
outside London, in London,
dropped on Big Ben.
Let's say Ben, London, outside--
something like that.
He could choose one of three.
Now, the fact that he
decided to say London
could include Big Ben.
But if it was Ben, he
could have also said Ben.
He didn't, which implies that
it probably fell over here.
So the last model that I wanted
to show you was exactly that.
You sort of say, listen,
there's some prior.
The bombs sort of fall anywhere.
And there's some distance here.
And let's say you start out
with just random gibberish.
You can say either Ben
or outside or inside.
It doesn't matter.
Regardless of what the
world actually was,
this is just defining what
each one of these words mean.
To hit London means to be
inside that small square I said.
To hit Ben means to
be inside that smaller
square inside London.
To hit outside means
to hit outside.
That's what they mean.
It just gives you back a true
or false on a particular point
in a two-dimensional space.
Is it true or is it
false that this happened?
Now, you have a speaker
and a listener model.
And the way that
the speaker works
is that he has a
particular state in mind.
Like, he's looking at
the state of the world.
The bomb fell here.
And he needs to
communicate something.
And he's reasoning about the
listener to a particular depth.
What he's going to
do is he's going
to choose a word randomly,
because our prior is random.
Kind of like before, we
chose an action at random,
and we saw if it worked, he's
going to use a word at random.
And he's going to
choose the word such
that it's going to cause the
right state in the listener.
So he needs a model
of the listener.
What's the listener?
The listener is someone
who takes in a word
and tries to figure
out the state.
He doesn't know what happened.
Where did the bomb fall?
Someone gives him a word.
And he's trying to
figure out the state.
So he's drawing a
state from the prior.
And this prior is,
it could be anywhere.
It could be anywhere
in the square.
Where did it actually fall?
Well, it fell here,
let's say, given that I
got this particular word.
But this word was
generated by a speaker,
which I need a model of.
So there's this model of
the speaker understanding
the listener, and a
model of the listener
understanding the speaker
up to a particular depth.
And they need to bottom
out at some point.
And it's not that hard.
I mean, it takes some time
to wrap your head around it.
But it's written about
eight lines of code.
And that's why I
said that Church--
remember that caveat I gave you
of, it's not a toy language.
It's under development.
But it's actually been doing
some pretty interesting stuff.
This is one of those things.
These sort of language
games are really
hard to write in
many other models--
really hard to write.
And here, it's kind of trivial.
You can sort of see
where to play with it.
I came up with this
example yesterday.
And I asked Andreas, which is
my go-to guy for these things,
and he thought it
was interesting.
So you would run that.
And let's say that the
speaker said it hit London.
What should the
listener understand.
Where is this
distribution over it?
And I've sort of
just sampled from it.
I've sampled from
his distribution
over where he thinks it fell.
And I just did a few samples,
but you can sort of notice
the suspicious gap over here.
And if I sample
100 points, you'll
notice that it's going
to be in London--
so between one and one.
This might take it a minute.
But what you'll end up seeing
is that it's probably anywhere
in London.
If someone said to
you, it fell in London,
then you infer that
it's anywhere in London
except Big Ben.
Because if it was Big Ben,
you would have said Big Ben.
It's not perfect.
I mean, there are some
samples that get there.
It's actually some
shifting distribution.
But yeah.
If you took some heat
map of this thing, what
you would end up
with is that there's
some sort of suspicious
emptiness over here.
In this case, there's also a
bit of an emptiness over there.
But in the limit,
you'll get that.
So we did plan B, which was
to zoom through a few things
very quickly.
I'm sure you guys didn't
fully grok the details.
And that's OK.
What I wanted to
do with plan B was
to give you a taste
of what is possible
and how you would go
about writing models.
The important things
to remember here
is that probabilistic
programs are
great tools for capturing
lots of rich structure--
anything from physics to
psychology to language
games to grammar to vision.
Church is a particularly
useful language
for teaching yourselves
about these things.
There's a lot of
different models
that you can play
with on probmods.org.
You can write down a
generative model very easily
to describe how you
think the world works,
and then you can put that
in an inference engine
and try to figure out
what you actually saw.
OK.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]